plus de gaz russe pour la pologne et la
bulgarie pour moscou ces deux membres de
l'union européenne ne respectent pas les
nouvelles modalités de paiement exigé
par gazprom le mois dernier le président
russe vladimir poutine a demandé aux
pays jugés inamicaux de payer les
livraisons de gaz via un nouveau système
un paiement en deux étapes la facture
est réglée en devises étrangères avant
d'être converti en roubles puis
transféré à gazprom
l'an dernier la bulgarie importait plus
de 90% de son gaz de russie c'est près
de 57% pour la pologne mais le
gouvernement polonais se montre
rassurant et dès 2019 il avait informé
gasprom qu'il ne prolongerait pas son
contrat préférant développer le projet
baltik taille aps un gazoduc en
provenance de norvège qui devrait
couvrir la moitié de la consommation
polonaise d'ici quelques mois je me sens
quand on gagne et nous sommes prêtes à
être totalement coupée des ressources
aux russes nous avons imposé un embargo
sur le charbon le 16 avril nous sommes
prêts pour une coupure complète des
importations de gaz et de pétrole russe
mécontents vina les regards se tournent
maintenant vers l'allemagne et l'italie
deux poids lourds de l'économie
européenne
berlin a déjà réduit la part de ses
approvisionnements en gaz russe de 55 à
40% depuis le début de la guerre en
ukraine et vise les 30 % d'ici la fin de
l'année de son côté l'italie cherche à
diversifier ses sources
d'approvisionnement des contrats ont
déjà été conclus avec plusieurs pays
d'afrique